so let's do a couple of examples of the
number opposites exercise on khan
academy just to make sure that we've
really digested what it means to be the
opposite of a number so they have a
number line here and then they've marked
some of the numbers with letters and
this is a b c d e and then they say what
can we say about point b
and point b is one hash mark to the left
of zero all right select all that apply
so the first thing that says b is equal
to negative d
so that means that b needs to be the
opposite of d let's see if that's true d
is here d is one hash mark to the right
of zero the opposite of d
or negative d should be one hash mark to
the left of zero which is b
b is the opposite of d b is negative d
so this is true
the next statement is b is the opposite
of e
let's see e is one two three hash marks
to the right of zero so the opposite of
e should be
one two three hash marks to the left of
zero that is not b that is a
b is not the opposite of e a is the
opposite of e but that doesn't what they
write here so we're not going to check
that
and then they say b is equal to negative
b that's saying that b is the same thing
as the opposite of b
that is not true the opposite of b is
going to go on the other side of the
number line that's d which is not b
so this is also not true this would have
been true they said c is equal to
negative c
because c is at zero it's a zero away
from zero z is zero the opposite of zero
is going to be zero away on the other
side of the number line well that's
still zero away so zero is negative zero
or we could have said c is equal to
negative c that the only number for
which that is true is
zero
it's not going to be true for b because
b is clearly not zero
so let's let's do let's do a couple of
here what can we say about negative c
all right so now c is zero select all
apply
negative c
is zero yeah the negative of zero is
going to still be zero
the negative of zero the opposite zero
is still going to be zero
the opposite of zero well that's not
going to be this number this is some
non-zero number so
that's that
all right what can we say about point t
well t once again is at zero so we say t
is zero
zero is the opposite of zero it is equal
to negative zero
both of them one is zero you could say
zero to the left one is zero to the
right well that still means that they're
still on zero they're right they aren't
zero
t is equal to the opposite of the
opposite of t
well this would actually be true for any
number for any number the opposite of
the opposite is going to be that number
we could have put the q here the r here
really for any number the opposite of
the opposite is going to be that number
again and so it's definitely going to be
true for 0 as well so that's definitely
going to be true so hopefully that gives
you a little bit more practice with
number opposites and helps you digest
things a little bit more